de nouveaux visages.
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
- Dans le Quartier des
spectacles, l'équipe de Juste
pour rire met la dernière touche
aux préparatifs du festival
qui débute demain. Et il y a
de la fébrilité dans l'air.
CATHERINE ÉTHIER, humoriste
- Je me sens, Nabi, un peu comme
à la veille d'un rendez-vous
amoureux quand ça fait longtemps
que t'en as eu, puis que
tu sais pu trop comment ça se
passe, mais tu sais qu'il faut
que tu mettes tes petits bas de
nylon et ton rouge à lèvre du
samedi soir, fait que c'est un
peu comme ça que je me sens.
- Jusqu'au 24 juillet,
les festivaliers pourront
assister en plein air à des
animations déambulatoires ou à
l'une des 60 représentations de
spectacles extérieurs gratuits.
PATRICK ROZON, vice-président
contenu Groupe Juste pour rire
- C'est le retour du bonheur,
c'est le retour de l'espoir
et c'est le retour aussi
d'une équipe complètement en feu
où on a réussi à réinventer
le festival en un mois.
- Pourquoi t'es célibataire?
- Et cette année encore,
le festival fait la part belle
aux nouveaux visages.
- Les humoristes connus,
on les connaît très, très bien,
mais à un moment donné la
nouvelle relève est là, puis
elle pousse. Ils ont énormément
de talent et il y a aussi
des humoristes de la diversité
qui sont à Montréal, qui sont
au Québec, mais qui avaient
jamais la porte d'entrée
pour venir à Juste pour rire
ou ailleurs.
- Parmi eux, Tai, une jeune
sensation des réseaux sociaux
qui transportera son humour
et son "Occupation Hood"
d'Instagram à la scène
de l'Olympia.
TAI TL, influenceur et humoriste
- Il y a beaucoup de diversité,
on retrouve vraiment de tout
dans le live. Tu vois, il y a
des Québécois, des Haïtiens,
des Arabes, des Latinos
et c'est ça qui fait en sorte
que le monde adore le live.
- En parallèle du festival
Juste pour rire, se déroule
le Zoofest au Monument national.
- Quand tu te bats avec une
fille, les poings, c'est pas
comme ça. C'est comme ça.
- L'occasion pour le public de
découvrir de nouveaux talents
et pour les humoristes de la
relève, de monter sur scène
dans de bonnes conditions.
Sinem Kara s'y produira
pour la quatrième fois.
SINEM KARA, humoriste
- C'est la possibilité d'avoir
des salles professionnelles,
du matériel professionnel,
puis jouer dans des conditions
humaines.
- Le festival Juste pour Rire
est le premier grand événement
culturel à se tenir sur
la Place des Festivals
depuis le début de la pandémie.
De quoi ramener des gens
dans le centre-ville et des
sourires sur les visages
des commerçants, avec l'espoir
que les meilleurs jours sont
à venir.
Ici Nabi-Alexan